hey all Peter Kumble feed roses here to
discuss Blanca and Ultra Street Fighter
4 Blanca has always been a tricky
character but once his tricks were
figured out he felt pretty far in the
ring would that be the case this time
around let's look at his changes in c4
Blanca players to effectively score a
combo damage they had to perform
extremely difficult links that left no
room for error this has been addressed
by adding more advantage to his
crouching middle King on hit now Blanca
players can score more damage while
landing combos that starts from
crouching middle kick or consistently
due to the increased leniency certain
matches for Blanca were extremely
difficult due to him being punished when
landing a Blanca ball successfully
against the opponent this resulted in
Blanca players sacrificing damage so
that they would not be punished for
playing correctly in an effort to fix
this the heavy Blanca ball has been
adjusted to knock down from all ranges
Blancas escape options when he slapped
down a rather non-existence once the
opponent realizes his only option is a
rainbow roll to add some versatility to
his wakeup game all versions of Blancas
vertical rolling are now focused
counselor Blanca's ultra shot of earth
provided him with much needed options
against both airborne and ground
opponents
unfortunately the difficulty associated
with landing the anti-air version of
ultra 2 was rather high due to the
narrow hitbox on the attack
it would also miss against certain
characters that performed after a focus
of power this has since been resolved
with the increase of the hitbox size
during all active brain
Blanca has definitely improved in Ultra
Street Fighter hi Blanca players now
have the ability to pursue damage
through the effective use of a crunchy
little cake as well as the use of his
heavy horizontal rolling attack
traditionally Blanca now has a new
escape option and that opponents must
take into account when the pressuring
him making him more balanced overall
with the right combination of trickery
damage and hard to read movements Blanca
players will be a bit more difficult to
deal with this time around
you